Now let's add those other cats.
First I'll copy all my cat's
from our last cat clicker.
And I'm putting the cat data
at the very top of this file.
Now I've put the cat data
at the top of the file,
but I also could load
this data from a server.
And when the list came
back from the server,
I could add them to the application.
That'd be trivial to implement, and you
can do it for extra credit if you want.
Now what am I going to do with
this array of cat objects?
Well, down here in the ViewModel,
I'm going to want to create cats, and
I'll want to store them
in an observable array.
I'm going to call it, catList.
Now you'll notice I'm not passing
in the array at the top of the file
right into this yet.
That's because I need
to take that data and
make a new cat out of
each of those objects.
I'm going to loop over
all of our initial cats.
And for each one of the cats,
I'm going to put it into the cat list.
Here we are doing a very
similar thing as we did.
Here, but
instead of passing in an object literal,
we're passing in each of the cat items
in that initial cat array at the top.
You'll also notice we're using
the var self equals this trick.
That way if we say this dot cat list,
we don't end up getting confused
with what this function believes
that this keyword maps to.
Self is always going to
map to the view model.
So self.catList is going
to map to this cat list.
This observable array right here.
Now I am forgetting one other
thing which is the nicknames.
I'm going to grab our nicknames
from tabby up here and
I'm going to put them
in our initial data.
I'm also going to add a nickname from
Tiger to Tigger, Scaredy to Casper,
Shadow to Shooby, and Sleepy to Zzzzz.
Now my initial cat data has nicknames.
And in the ViewModel,
I'm looping over all the initial cats.
And pushing a new cat with each of
the cat items into the cat list.
Pretty good.
I'm also going to change this right
here to this.catList, item zero.
That way we're not creating
a new cat for the current cat.
Here we're making all
of the cats we need,
we don't need to create another one.
We just need to access the 0th element
in the cat list or our first cat.
Now we have a bit more work to do.
First, we need to make all
the cats show up in a list.
That should be a list of your cats on
the screen that users can click on.
You should be able to do that
entirely in your HTML with bindings.
Second we need to make the cats
in the cat list clickable.
When you click on the cat
name in the list,
it should change the current cat
observable to the new clicked cat.
That means we'll need to make a function
for setting the new current cat.
Those are the two main things
that you still have to do.
Make the cat show up, and
make the current cat change when you
click on one of those cats on the list.
Now take your time with this one.
Don't make a bunch of stabs in the dark.
The amount of code you'll need to do all
of this is actually pretty small, so
take the effort to really try and
understand what you need to do.
And what tools you have to do it.
Oh, and once you're done,
give yourself a high five.
You deserve it.